[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
mal mit einer orientalischen dattel
füllung das sind feine gries kekse und
die sind auch extra nicht so süß
gehalten ich habe das originalrezept von
meiner schwiegermutter so wie man das
schwägerin und die kekse die schmecken
unglaublich lecker zum tee oder zum
kaffee
wie in all meinen videos findet ihr die
genauen mengenangaben immer unten in der
infobox und wir starten zuallererst mit
dem christ hierfür benötigen wir
weichweizen gries mehl butter oder
margarine butter zucker orangenblüten
wasser außerdem ein wenig milch
gemahlenen fenchel sowie gemahlin anis
ein wenig macht etwas muskatnuss
neutrales öl und trockenhefe und keine
panik vor den außergewöhnlichen zutaten
die wir hier verwenden die findet ihr
alle im arabischen oder türkischen
supermarkt
zuallererst geben wir die trockenen
zutaten bis auf die gewürze in eine
große schüssel hier haben wir zum einen
weichweizen gries mail puderzucker und
die hefe und das wird dann gut
miteinander verrührt
[Musik]
bei den gewürzen müsst ihr schauen ob
ihr das je nach dem stärker oder weniger
stark wirkt im geschmack zum beispiel
habe ich hier einen teelöffel nach la
punt jeweils einen halben teelöffel
ventil und anis genommen da könnt ihr
ruhig vertrauen das schmeckt dann so
ziemlich angenehm und auch nicht zu
stark und das habe ich jetzt auch noch
mit untergerührt und jetzt geht es
weiter mit der butter
an der stelle könnt ihr auch nehmen was
euch lieber schmeckt ob ihr jetzt butter
oder margarine nimmt ist da vollkommen
egal ich mag mutter immer lima deswegen
habe ich hier butter verwendet und wenn
ihr das so ein wenig unter getötet habt
dann kommt auch schon das öl mit hinzu
beim öl solltet ihr jetzt unbedingt
darauf achten dass es neutral schmeckt
also kein olivenöl oder irgendetwas
außergewöhnliches nimmt am besten
sonnenblumen oder rapsöl
beinahe hätte ich die muskatnuss
vergessen also gibt die auch noch mit
hinein das könnt ihr natürlich auch
vorher schon mit hinein geben eine gute
prise reicht hier da kommt der geschmack
auch schon ganz gut zur geltung
[Musik]
hier könnt ihr sehen dass butter und öl
noch nicht die perfekte konsistenz
hervorgebracht haben deswegen brauchen
wir noch ein wenig flüssigkeit und dafür
dient jetzt die milch und auch das
orangenblüten wasser
[Musik]
die milch gebt ihr dann am besten
schlückchen weise mit hinzu denn dann
kann man das viel besser einschätzen und
am besten arbeitet er auch wirklich mit
den händen und nicht mit einer
küchenmaschine denn so weiß man wirklich
wann der teig dann bereit ist
[Musik]
zu guter letzt geben wir noch drei
esslöffel orangenblüten wasser mit in
den teig und darauf würde ich auch
wirklich nicht verzichten denn dann habt
ihr den typisch orientalischen geschmack
und orangenblüten wasser findet ihr in
jedem orientalischen supermarkt die sind
doch gar nicht teuer so eine flasche
kostet um die 1 euro hält meistens ein
bis zwei jahre je nachdem wie oft
gepackt und dann ist der tag auch schon
fertig für die füllung habe ich hier
bereits entkernten datteln das sind
jetzt insgesamt 800 gramm das gewicht
nachdem die dateien entfernt wurden
außerdem ein wenig wasser öl zimt und
geröstetem sesam für die dattel passte
müssen zuallererst die datteln ein wenig
kleiner geschnitten werden hierfür habe
ich sie schreibe sie dann in ganz
kleinen stückchen und gebe sie in eine
große schüssel
[Musik]
da kommt noch das wasser mit hinzu und
das ganze wird dann für ca drei minuten
in der mikrowelle auf höchster stufe
erhitzt
nun sind die daten sehr sehr heiß also
lasst sie am besten ein paar minuten
abkühlen das habe ich ja auch getan
danach gebe ich den zimt und den sesam
mit hinzu und verknetet das zu einer
paste
[Musik]
jetzt solltet ihr eine richtig schöne
datteln asse haben die aber noch ein
bisschen klebrig ist ich hatte hier noch
ein paar stückchen drin ist kommt halt
immer drauf an wie frisch eure daten
sind und ich habe sie bei mir noch ein
paar sekunden in den mixer gegeben dass
es aber völlig optional
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das im video so
gut sehen könnt aber die dattel paste
ist noch ziemlich klebrig und deshalb
brauchen wir auch das öl das gehen wir
noch mit hinzu und nachdem wir das auch
unter geglättet haben ist die dattel
passte fertig
übrigens gibt es diese titel passte auch
fertig zu kaufen jedoch um gewürzt er
müsste dann nur noch eure gewürzen
mithin zu tun
ich habe euch aber bewusst die
hausgemachte methode gezeigt
[Musik]
so nun kommt der spaßige teil jetzt
können wir unsere mammut endlich formen
und dafür gibt es auch extra solche
geräte beziehungsweise solche förmchen
die gibt es in verschiedenen variationen
da könnt ihr einfach schauen welche euch
am liebsten gefällt am besten bereitet
ihr euch jetzt so kügelchen vor dida
befüllung die habe ich zu einer
kleineren kugel geformt und anschließend
den teig den habe ich zu einer größeren
kugel geformt denn das muss ja dann
anschließend hinein passen und so könnt
ihr systematisch arbeiten und eine nach
der anderen formen zuallererst nehmt ihr
euch nun eine gries kugel und formte mit
dem finger entweder mit dem daumen oder
mit dem zeigefinger eine mulde gibt da
die datei kugel mit hinein und
verschließt sie wieder
ich habe mich hier für die kleine form
entschieden weil ich total süß fand und
da gebe ich jetzt ein stück folie drauf
presse die vorbereitete kugel hinein die
nimmt dann auch so richtig schön die
form an und anschließend werfen wir es
einfach raus und dass man wohl ist fast
fertig
[Musik]
hier zeige ich euch noch eine andere
form die ich total hübsch fand dafür
nehme ich den kreistag und mache das von
vornherein so dass sich die mulde ein
wenig breiter ausdrücke dann gebe ich
die da die füllung hinein die habe ich
auch schon flach angedrückt es macht mir
die arbeit ein bisschen leichter und
dann verschließe ich das und gäbe dass
in die form hinein
[Musik]
für diese form benötigt ihr keine
frischhaltefolie denn durch den auswurf
könnt ihr die form einfach heraus
pressen und das mammut ist unbeschädigt
nun gebe ich die mammuts auf ein mit
backpapier ausgelegtes backblech und sie
werden anschließend bei 220 grad zehn
bis zwölf minuten gebacken wobei die
kleinen beim mit 10 minuten und die
breiten zwölf minuten gebraucht haben
wenn sie goldbraun sind dann sind sie
genau richtig ich habe sich hier schon
abkühlen lassen und verzieren sie dann
noch mit puderzucker
[Musik]
besonders gern gesehen sind die mammuts
bild haben wir auch gerade jetzt zum
opferfest oder auch zum zuckerfest falls
ihr gäste bekommt dann sehr gut jedoch
zum tee das macht immer ganz schön was
her
[Musik]
hier zeige ich euch den sehr fein keks
auch noch mal von innen ich hoffe ihr
seht wie zart der ist zusammen mit der
dattel füllung eine super kombination
und falls ihr jetzt auch noch
vorbereitungen treffen müsst für das
opferfest oder die kekse einfach so nach
machen möchtet dann schaut man in die
infobox da habe ich alles aufgeschrieben
was ihr wissen müsst und ich freue mich
über euer abo damit ihr auch nichts mehr
von mir verpasst bis zum nächsten mal
auf dieses kitchen